triste nouvelle dans le monde de la
téléphonie mobile il ya un des acteurs
historiques un acteur qu'on qualifie
très très très très très longtemps
peut-être pas vous en tout cas moi oui
c'est sûr eh bien vous le dirai après
tout à l'heure en barrant commentaire
cet acteur c est une marque de téléphone
à vannes est une marque de smartphones
qui est là depuis fin des années 90
début des années 2000 qui est une marque
extrêmement forte
une marque qui avait une notion très
premium et qui a vu un peu une image de
marque businessman très classe cette
marque elle a beaucoup souffert n'avait
pas su prendre le virage du smartphone à
la fin des années 2000 début d'année
elle a eu beaucoup de mal c'était très
très compliqué et aujourd'hui c'est une
marque qui ferme la porte qui baissent
le rideau qui se tint mines qui arrête
le smartphone qui le commercialisent
rapide smartphone pour qui bien sûr on
pourra plus acheter de smartphones alors
ça ça manque beaucoup de choses avant de
vous dire effectivement de qui il s'agit
ça montre un point très important c'est
effectivement la concurrence très très
dur très très rude dans tout ce
marché-là du smartphone qui est normal
de plus en plus d'acteurs qui arrive qui
apparaissent avec beaucoup de produits
qui se ressemblent beaucoup de produits
qui sont réellement similaires là pour
le coup une aventure qui était
extrêmement différenciant mais qui
malgré tout n'a pas suffi cette marque
ses blackberry alors blackberry je sais
pas si beaucoup d'essais je sais pas si
vous avez connu je sais pas si vous avez
ou si vous aviez aux produits blackberry
ou pourquoi pas est ce que vous aviez
l'intention en hausse tient d'ailleurs
dit club a tout de suite en bas en
commentaire la grosse difficulté qu'on
compte aujourd'hui blackberry et bien
tout simplement un marché saturé un
marché complexe
ils n'ont pas réussi à trouver leur
clientèle en tout cas suffisamment
important de suffisamment non pour me
racheter leur smartphone blackberry pas
si vous connaissez ce sont les
smartphones avec un clavier physique à
clavier qui vous servira effectivement
alors vos petites touches sous le doigt
pour venir taper tapoter vos textes très
facilement alors qu'à une époque il ya
très longtemps vous aviez que le t9 pour
être clair que si vous avez connu que
vous preniez un nokia 33-10 de l'époque
où des produits comme ça eh bien vous en
étiez appuie plusieurs fois sur une
touche pour trouver votre lettre c'était
un peu compliqué on avait certains qui
étaient très très fort mais j'avais des
potes qui étaient extrêmement fort pour
tâter très vite antennes neuf mais je
suis relativement compliqué alors
backberry du coup proposé lui une
alternative un vrai clavier physique
c'était très facile de taper vous allez
vite vers une vraiment notion business
derrière qui se développait qui était
vraiment très très forte avec l'arrivée
du smartphone et l'extension du
smartphone et bien un blackberry a eu du
mal a eu beaucoup de mal d'années
avaient leur propre os en 2015 et son
arrivée sur android en 2016 c'était
celle qui a acheté la licence est ce
possible qu'au décès est un acteur
majeur chinois qui connut notamment au
travers des téléviseurs ils ont donc eu
la licence de blackberry de 2016 à 2020
et là il annonçait effectivement qu'ils
arrêtaient la licence était terminée
stop
on en veut plus ça répond à une
stratégie double je voulais voilerait à
la fin de la vidéo
d'ailleurs dès maintenant je vous invite
à vous abonner ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous serez tôt pour parler de
teck et puis surtout laissez moi un joli
petit pouce en bas de cette vidéo sort
un petit qu'autant de poussan voir si
vous êtes nombreux et nombreuses à
l'essai des jolies poussent vers le haut
pour permettre cette vidéo de progresser
et d'être mieux référencés sur youtube
c'est l'algorithme ça fonctionne comme
ça que voulez vous je sais pas si vous
êtes intéressé à la question de la halle
berry mais en quelques années sorti
quelques produits il ya eu le kit ou des
produits qui prend le coup des vraiment
différenciant dans un marché extrêmement
saturés ou les smartphones se
ressemblent les uns les autres de plus
en plus on pourrait se dire ok pour une
fois qu'une proposition de valeur qui
est différente
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas marché
mais je pense que ce qui est compliqué
avec dan berry c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
gens en veulent de l'innovation veulent
du smartphone veulent des produits qui
fonctionnent un peu différent sion mais
on veut qu'ils devront clavier on veut
pas un clavier qui vont occuper la
moitié de la face avant pour smartphones
même s'il ya un côté pratique ça répond
avant tout à une problématique dans les
années 2000 beaucoup moins dans les
années 2010 est carrément pas dans les
années 2020
ou alors être population extrêmement
nicher ce qui ne génèrent pas
suffisamment de ventes de masse pour ce
soit rentable et intérêts sont bien que
berry pour moi ç'a vraiment l'image du
professionnel ont dit ok je suis un
projet mon blackberry j'utilise pour
aller travailler
je vais rentrer mes notes je vais taper
facilement mais honnêtement aujourd'hui
comme des professionnels la plupart du
temps que l'entreprise vous donne des
smartphones premium que ce soit chez
apple samsung consorts ou autre vous
avez un smartphone premium est souvent
les smartphones ont même des doubles cap
sinon vous mettez votre carte sim peur
sur votre carte sim pro et ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui dans les usages
on va pas nécessairement aller chercher
un clavier physique un blackberry
d'autant plus que ça va venir renier
vraiment aujourd'hui une fois de plus un
point très très très très important la
moitié de votre smartphone donc la
proposition de valeur qui a fabriqué la
marque et qui a donné tout l'intérêt la
marque aujourd'hui elle est dépassée et
ça ne peut plus réellement fonctionné pc
elle a donc fait le choix d'arrêter sa
licence les smartphones blackberry
s'arrêteront définitivement le 31 août
2020 il eu raison quelques mois à vivre
avant que le rideau ton soit terminée
alors
rassurez vous si vous avez un smartphone
blackberry si vous en avez le temps n'y
a pas longtemps si vous faites partie
des chanceux qui ont acheté un
smartphone blackberry
et bien sachez qu'ils vont assurer le
sav jusqu'en 2022 je vous 31 août 2022
sont les obligations légales
donc au moins de ce côté là vous êtes
quand même couleur vous sera quand même
relativement tranquille ne pensait pas
derrière à la revente je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient beaucoup de personnes
qu'ils aillent acheter un blackberry
dans les années à venir d'occasion ou
alors pourquoi pas un smartphone qui
sera comme la collector on va ça répond
vraiment une question stratégique de la
part de tcl est aujourd'hui testé elle
est très connue comme je le disais pour
les téléviseurs il se développe de plus
en plus moi qui fais pas mal de salon
tesselles voulais retrouver dans
beaucoup d'endroits ils ont des produits
qui sont vraiment cool qui marche bien
des baux téléviseur et compagnie mais
ils développent eux-mêmes leur propre
gamme de smartphones lorsque j'étais
notamment à vegas à quelques jours au cs
j'allais faire un petit tour ou des du
stand de tcl qui m'ont tout le côté
téléviseurs mais il y avait aussi un
côté smartphones avec des smartphones
qui a été montré entrée milieu de gamme
vraiment axé sur le milieu de gamme et
des produits sous cloche j'en ai déjà
parlé dans une précédente vidéo des
smartphones pliable un smartphone qui se
plie un peu comme un petit bouquin vous
avez l'esprit de proto de smartphones
qu'ils se plieraient en 3 le smartphone
qui se plie en deux fonctionnent si
j'avais des images avait une
présentation presse il ya quelques jours
il a été montré on pouvait le prendre en
main et sac chose qui fonctionne le
produit expliquant 3 ça ressemblait plus
à un proto a une vision de l'avenir dans
la mesure où tcl nous montre des proto
sous cloche c'est qu'ils ont une
perspective de développement sur la
production de masse dans les années à
venir
donc à mon avis ce que cherche à faire
tcl se dire ok aujourd'hui blackberry
ces licences qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
trop nicher ils ont effectivement des
connaissances peuvent se développer là
dessus mais la marque blackberry n'est
pas suffisamment forte donc on arrête on
se sépare de galeries et on va bien
travailler en marque propre en eau
propre sous la marque tcl sur une gamme
extrêmement large pour moi l'idée d'un
tcl c'est devenir copier ce que fait
samsung c'est à dire avoir un écosystème
global sur de la télé sur plein de
produits mais également sur du
smartphone entrée milieu de gamme e de
gamme et du pliable ont effectivement
sur cette stratégie de marché avec
beaucoup de produits au catalogue et mon
avis c'est vraiment là-dessus crainte
est celle ils ont racheté blackberry en
disant ok c'est une licence forte elle
est connue c'est le pari de travailler
là dessus de faire du business mais la
stratégie une fille laissée de bosser
pour eux sous la marque tcl et que vous
achetiez des produits tcl parce que si
vous achetez un smartphone tcl il se
peut très probablement vous aviez acheté
ensuite
les desert hessel pourquoi pas plein de
produits d'un écosystème tcs c'est à
dire la stratégie de nombreuses marques
dont xiaomi avec un écosystème
extrêmement large apple consorts j'en
passe et des meilleurs d'ailleurs il ya
une conférence de tcl qui aura lieu au
mwc à barcelone d'ici quelques jours je
vais aller les voir je vais les voir un
peu ce qui se passe je vous dirai tout
bien évidemment en vidéo sur youtube sur
instagram sur les différents réseaux
sociaux et même jour tik tok dont je
vous invite à vous abonner à me
rejoindre sur tous les réseaux sociaux
comme ça vous saurez tout quant à
blackberry la société continue à exister
même bien avant qu'ils revendent la
licence à tcl blackberry travaille sur
des solutions pour le professionnel des
solutions large dont blackberry continue
à exister mais par contre je pense que
les smartphones blackberry
on n'est pas près de les avoir sur ce je
donne rendez vous demain pour continuer
à parler de teck
laissez-moi des jolies pouces abonnez
vous et dites moi ce que vous pensez
vous de blackberry quelle image vous
avez deux blackberry qu'à l'image vous
avez de la marque et est ce que vous
pourriez vous aujourd'hui en 2020
acheter un smartphone blackberry neufs
ou d'occasion mark et moi tout ça c'est
non on se retrouve dès demain les bisous
et à demain
ciao
je
[Musique]
oui
contre